can you give us five filmmaking tips for
anyone who wants to make a movie first
of all have a good screenplay that's the
most important thing have a good
screenplay number two make sure you have
the resources to make the film don't
rush into making the film unless you
have the resources to pay for the the
camera equipment the locations and
personnel the third one is have a really
good producer who knows but they are
doing and be very very selective in who
you hire so have a good script have the
resources to make the film hire a really
really good producer be polite and
respectful and grateful to every crew
member and cast member very very very
important and one way you can show
gratitude is by feeding people well keep
keep the morale up and number five be
open to the suggestions if an actor I
did a film with Rena Olin really great
actors from Once Were Warriors and she's
on another plane I mean her her acting
is she's she's not it's not mental and
it's the character it's it's amazing and
so I would block things out and she
would say well I was thinking oh ma
would do it this way I said yes you're
right let's do it you have to be open
don't let your ego get in the way of the
process because that will really mess
you up if you're working with an actress
that has been acting like for 30 40
years and you've been directing for five
years listen to that actress so be open
to taking guidance or suggestions
because it will make you feel better
what was the biggest mistake you made in
the beginning on a film set off so I had
directed a music video for a company
called oil factory and um I got assigned
a cinematographer I didn't get to pick
him and I would ask him to do something
and you would do it
and he just I would say shoot it this
way and he was shooted another way and
the mistake I made was I didn't stand up
for my vision
I said well I guess this is what I have
to do I was just out of film school oh
my god I guess well he's an ass I guess
sometimes you have to work with asses
but the music video did not end up being
a good video why because he had no
interested in executing my vision and I
don't know what this guy was about but
the mistake I made was not standing up
for my vision in front of everybody I
was too shy about it you know and I'll
never make that I'll never make that
mistake again the same thing though I'm
gonna talk about that
but you have to defend your vision
you must defend your vision and if
there's someone that it's not helping
you execute the vision cut them off
because the the video was a nightmare
but I learned from it that will never
happen again
you